is easing its lockdown but doctors are
sounding the alarm
death rates are among the highest in the
world
still stores are reopening with the
government praising its vaccination
campaign
at the same time as banning journalists
from hospitals
coronavirus boards are filling to
capacity
but that's not the message the state
wants to broadcast
like it or not the third wave is hitting
hard
hungary has the highest number of people
vaccinated in europe
and one of the highest covert related
death rates worldwide
relative to its population healthcare
workers say restrictions should have
been in place sooner and should stay in
place longer
access to hungarian hospitals for
independent media to verify what's going
on
is almost impossible dw met one doctor
who dared to speak on camera about the
situation inside
our correspondent fannie farchar reports
soldiers monitor people checking into
this hospital treating covet patients
when we start to film the building go
there and do your tv thing
over there they ask us to film the
parking lot
according to staff inside the hospital
is at capacity
one doctor has to take care of 10 covet
patients
and oxygen is in short supply these are
just some of the claims we're hearing
from
inside the hospital from a doctor but we
cannot
verify these claims as authorities have
barred independent media
from entering that doctor is gabor
zachar
we meet him after his shift 120 hour
working weeks
are the average now he says but the
hungarian government says
everything is under control
we've heard a lot from the prime
minister that those who get sick
shouldn't worry that they will be cured
that we have extra medical staff but
where are they every day we're left
wondering
what did we not have time for today what
did i forget
most of his colleagues don't want to
talk in public because they are worried
about repercussions
we need to reach the people not to
create panic but to say people
this is what this is about and this is
why you need to follow the rules
in an open letter to the government a
large number of journalists requested
access to hospitals prime minister
viktor uban responded in a televised
interview
this is not the time to go inside
hospitals and produce bogus videos and
fake news
is a photojournalist he too would like
to show what's happening in hungary
right now
stop filming the hospital it's a public
space sir
it's a very common situation says martin
samar this affects the people who want
to know the real situation inside the
hospitals
we know that more than 300 people died
today
it's our job to tell the story behind
those numbers
meanwhile many young people in hungary
are starting to shed
their masks without knowing what's
really going on in hungary's hospitals
to them it might seem as if the pandemic
is already over
to shine a light on the situation in
hungary dorothya sikhra joins us she's a
senior researcher at the center for
social sciences
in budapest is it time to be easing
restrictions or is the crisis only
getting worse
good afternoon well my impression is
that the crisis is still you know not
not completely at its peak in hungary we
have
extremely high mortality rates of kavid
one of the highest in the world actually
of daily deaths around 300 per day
so that would suggest
not to ease restrictions yet
at the same time if i can jump in there
when the government's doing so well with
its vaccination drive
exactly that's the other thing we have a
very high vaccination rate at the same
time
but people who get into hospital they
have they are in a really terrible
situation currently in hungary
and these may be two to three factors i
would say
one of the one of them is um
the um is that the public
health institution as such has been
moved out
uh had its independence has been stopped
in 2017
and since then it has been under
direct political control so this means
that we are not
um getting enough information and
experts
cannot really channel their ideas
and their expertise into the system so
political
decisions are taking the lead
probably the other issue may be the
general cut
to the house has expenditure in hungary
recently
not only recently but particularly under
the urban government
and the third one is the mass of out
migration
of health care staff from hungary in the
in the past decade
how is the situation with these
hospitals under military rule
why is that and and what's how's that
affecting the situation
well yeah hospitals have been put under
military rule
under the emergency situation and
this means that there is a direct
control through
a direct political and military control
over doctors and also that they cannot
um express their opinions
in the media really and the media is not
let into
hospitals this would not directly affect
the situation you know how people are
cared for because
our doctors and nurses are doing an
amazing job there
but it limits the information that the
public
and the media may get and that is you
know worrying
whatever the situation may be um
[Music]
freedom of uh information usually
helps better decisions what's the
situation like for regular hungarians i
believe this is one of the only
countries in the world
to refuse any sort of extension of
unemployment benefits in this pandemic
yes the pandemic as we know does not
only have health-related consequences
but also
really severe social consequences
so in hungary just like in other parts
of the world
many people hundreds of thousands have
lost their jobs
but as opposed to other countries
including
or fellow central eastern european
countries
in hungary no extensions to the
unemployment benefit system was made
which was which which was the weakest
actually in the developed bird even
before the pandemic
with three months of a maximum length of
unemployment
insurance benefit that means that after
that three months is gone you can or
cannot
receive some social assistance at a very
low
amount and in general as well
about half about 50 percent of all
unemployed people are not
registered at all in the state system so
they are left without
any public assistance
when they are longer term unemployed
and this now affects a great bunch of
people
especially those who have worked in
in restaurants in catering sectors and
so on and so forth
i also believe the government's used the
crisis to push through emergency
measures to make life harder for the
lgbt community yes some of the emergency
measures have
not much to do with covets itself but
rather the government's political
intention to push through
controversial measures including for
instance
the ban of single persons to adopt
children
and this is to counter gay couples
adoption possibilities
and the other one is that
transsexual people were banned to change
their sex in their ids
which again does not have to do with
anything with a pandemic but rather an
ideological intention of the government
to um to celebrate
uh traditional gender values
okay we'll have to leave it there on the
latest developments in budapest
thank you very much thank you so much
on the topic of mass vaccination
campaigns and mutations
here's our very own derek williams with
today's view question
is there a link between mass vaccination
and mutation of the virus
like other pathogens saris cov2
mutates constantly and vaccines do have
an impact
on its evolution but a less direct one
than for example
a theoretical antiviral treatment would
because the two work in different ways
drugs work
by wiping out an active infection
while vaccines work by preventing them
from occurring in the first place wiping
out an existing infection
with a medicine applies a kind of
scorched earth selection pressure
the only pathogens that survive are
those
like these with mutations that make them
resistant to the medicine
and only they go on to spawn the next
generation that's why drug resistance
is such a common problem nowadays
because
we put pathogens under massive pressure
to evolve
quickly in a very particular direction
which is to grow resistant to a
medication
by deploying vaccines on a wide scale
we're also having an impact on virus
evolution but a more
subtle one by making a lot of people
resistant to infection
we can drastically reduce opportunities
for a virus to spread
so we're also upping the selection
pressure
but in a different way when the supply
of potential hosts
grows limited because many people are
vaccinated
viruses that have for example mutated to
be more
infectious they'll have a clear
advantage and will on average
infect more people that's why
more infectious variants can supplant
less infectious ancestral ones over time
and and there are indications that this
is happening
in many places now with cyrus kobe too
thanks for watching stay safe and see
you again soon
[Music]
you